we begin the day asking will this be the
week that war returns to europe russia
continues sending more troops to its
border with ukraine a hundred and thirty
thousand strong so many that the
pentagon says an invasion could begin at
any moment and yet the kremlin's line
remains there are no plans to attack
the european union nato and the u.s are
not taking vladimir putin at his word
another week of shuttle diplomacy is
underway to de-escalate tensions german
chancellor olaf schultz and ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky met today in
kiev tomorrow schultz travels to moscow
for talks with vladimir putin germany is
warning russia any military move against
ukraine will bring severe consequences
hello hello mr chancellor nice to meet
you
a warm welcome in uncertain times
chancellor olaf schultz's first visit
here in kiev took place amid fears of a
russian invasion and so the meeting with
his ukrainian counterpart turned into a
more than two hour long crisis talk at
the joint press conference afterwards
zelensky reiterated his country's desire
to join nato despite russia's demands
for guarantees it would not
many leaders hint slightly that ukraine
shouldn't take the risk of talking
constantly about membership of the
alliance
because this risk is connected to
russia's reaction
i think no one is hiding it anymore i
think we should be sincere
it's our decision to take anyway
both agreed however membership in the
near future is not in the cards just
like another thing kiev would like to
have german weapons to defend itself
instead schultz offered more money and
political support
here in kiev i am once again making
clear ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity are non-negotiable
for germany therefore we expect clear
steps from russia to de-escalate current
tensions
the german government is clear that
further military aggression against
ukraine would have serious political
economic and geostrategic consequences
for russia i will emphasize that
tomorrow in moscow
the west charles added was ready for
serious dialogue with russia over
security matters
for many here in kiev however talk is
not enough they want schultz to act now
he should sanction north stream too
so putin would not be able to blackmail
europe we understand that for germany it
might be painful because their uh
business their industry depends on gas
supply but
let's think about diversification of gas
and oil supply to the european union
the controversial gas pipeline however
was something schultz did not mention
yet again
instead he called on clear steps from
russia to de-escalate a claim he'll get
a chance to reiterate on tuesday when he
meets vladimir putin in moscow
and my first guest tonight is pavel
felgenhauer he's an analyst specializing
in the russian military he's based in
moscow
it's good to have you on the program
tonight when you look at where we are
right now
um do you think that vladimir putin will
order an invasion of ukraine this week
well really no one knows for sure
uh maybe yes maybe not of course the
russian official line is that russia is
not attacking anyone russia is a
peaceful nation and so on so that's
intentions but as it was well known and
quite often repeated in nato
headquarters during the cold war in the
70s and the 80s and tensions don't
really matter because intentions can
change overnight or even
in an hour's time what's important our
capabilities the capabilities have been
deployed the russian military is at the
super high state of readiness not only
around ukraine but
all of the russian military including
the strategic nuclear deterrent
and the russian navy in many places not
only in the black sea but in the
mediterranean and the baltic and the
barren sea in the sea of achotzk and
actually it's a very dangerous situation
because if someone miscalculated some
pilot some
captain of a ship or submarine
we could be in a very serious situation
there could begin
clashes
skirmishes between directly russian and
american military well mr falcon let's
talk about the situation on the ground
right now i mean it's mid-february and
vladimir putin he knows he has to use
winter and the frozen ground to his
advantage if he wants to use
russian tanks
time is running out though isn't it
because spring's coming
well it's a sure thing of course that
the time is running out and that is
basically a good thing
uh because um that means this present
crisis will
will
de-escalate
rather soon
it's a week or maybe a bit more when
it's going to kind of end
this way or that
but even if it does end
if it does escalate right now
there is no guarantee that it will not
go again in several months because you
need a more permanent political solution
uh for the problem well what do you
think does it seem right now very
forthcoming what do you think vladimir
putin wants does he want to move
invade ukraine and go for keeve or
does he want a land bridge linking
crimea with russia i mean is that really
where we should be looking for an
invasion if one takes place
well an escalation may take place the
russian military may move in
they have the capabilities there
most likely politically it would be
expedient to kind of exercise some kind
of blitzkrieg
a very swift and decisive military
campaign to defeat the ukrainian
military the russian military did that
already in
august 14 and february 15. most likely
they hope they can do it again i'm not
sure that russia has right now the
capability to occupy the entirety of
ukraine it's a
40-plus million big nation with a lot of
territory i don't think that russia
actually russia has a large standing
army but maybe not enough i'm not sure
that they want to really anyone is
thinking in those terms
because there it's well known that there
are
actually pro-russian people living in
ukraine well maybe at least 20 percent
of the population is would be maybe
welcoming russian of troops moving in
and
the the majority would not
so that means the russian military i
believe if they move in they're going to
try to
limit that to those areas of ukraine
which are russian speaking and where
they would accept expect at least some
more friendly
populations than in other parts
mr felgenhauer joining us tonight from
moscow we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thank you
a few minutes ago
i have welcomed the first soldiers of
our reinforcement forces it's a strong
signal that germany is willing and
capable to reinforce the battle group
immediately if needed
and within the next few days
i expect around 350 additional soldiers
and around 100 additional vehicles
that was the commander of german forces
in lithuania 350 additional german
troops have arrived in the country to
shore up nato's eastern flank now they
are the first contingent of
reinforcements
as you heard more troops and vehicles
are expected to arrive in the coming
days lithuania following the african
country mali
is now home to the second largest
foreign deployment of german forces
the soldiers form part of a nato battle
group which is designed to delay an
attack by
russia in the baltics and to buy time
for additional troops to reach
the front
lines
well our correspondent jack parrok he is
in vilnius lithuania for us tonight good
evening to you
jack so let's talk about what we're
seeing here 350 additional german troops
with more on the way
is this enough to deter the russians
from any military action
against the baltic states or is this
more symbolism
well it's certainly a symbolism but it
is also significant what we heard during
that press conference at kaunas airport
earlier where the first 70 of the
additional 350 troops were arriving
is that there will be not only artillery
soldiers not only recce reconnaissance
specialists and medics but also
interestingly that there will be
specialists in nuclear and biological
warfare that will be deployed into this
battle group these 350 extra takes the
troop numbers to somewhere near 1500
here in lithuania as part of that battle
group coordinated by nato and run by
the german commander there and
essentially what they're saying is that
they're trying to beef up they're trying
to be prepared they don't say that they
have any warnings necessarily of any
potential uh invasions into lithuania by
the russians but with everything going
on on the on the border there is a sense
here that this was this was something
that germany you know could do in order
to show support for the baltic nations
who've been
really concerned about everything that's
going on in ukraine for their own safety
as well
let's stay with that for a moment
jack i mean we are talking
almost non-stop about
the russian threat along the border
with ukraine
but a little further north
these baltic states you know they also
have russia as a neighbor i mean are
they worried that the russian threat
could soon be much greater than it is
now
they certainly are the government has
been raising alarm bells here in
lithuania the latvians the estonians the
poles as well have very similar concerns
all ex-soviet states and
while there wasn't quite the scenes uh
like we're seeing now in ukraine all of
these countries still have a huge
hangover and a lot of a fear of what
moscow could potentially do many people
here remember living under
under the soviet union and they're aware
of you know the fear of that potentially
maybe returning having said that i've
spoken to to younger people here on the
streets of vilnius and earlier in
calmness as well and there's an acute
concern among the younger generations
who perhaps didn't live under the soviet
union themselves
they are pretty pleased that these new
german troops have arrived a lot of
people we've spoken to say good yeah we
should get some more troops in and that
the readiness in this country needs to
be there they do fear the russian
aggression
that's going on firstly in ukraine but
also remember there's 10 days of
russian military drills going on
over the border in belarus as well yeah
i'm wondering too do people there feel
like nato is doing enough
for its eastern flank or do they feel
like sometimes they are part of the
forgotten eastern outposts
yeah there is a sense sometimes that
that's the case and also that you know
really they because they're so far on on
the sort of eastern edge of nato that
perhaps there's some nervousness uh you
know not to poke the bear as it were um
but i think what we're seeing now is
that nato allies understand that
deploying troops here is a relatively uh
you know positive step in in the sense
of getting onto the front foot if
anything were to happen but as we say
1500 troops here here in in lithuania
it's really nothing compared to the the
hundred thousand plus russian troops
over the over the border of ukraine but
uh you know as i say it's a symbol and
the
a lot of the people we've spoken to are
pretty pleased and the government of
lithuania has expressed
that they're very happy that these
german troops are now arriving yeah
numbers and symbols matter in this
crisis that's for sure jack parrik
joining us tonight from vilnius jack as
always thank you